We are back to Konigsberg, that is now
Kaliningrad, Russia.
And you have now
learned how to
build a mega-city from millions of DNA reads and
how to navigate in this city to assemble
the genomes.
And it looks like a very simple and natural
city building approach
[UNKNOWN]
AFTER, only AFTER we learned how to do
this.
But it took bioinformaticians
[UNKNOWN]
two decades to figure out how to
apply Euler's idea to fragment assembly.
In fact, transforming real and often
convoluted biological problems into
elegant algorithmic
challenges is one of the most difficult
and rewarding tasks in bioinformaticsed.
[INAUDIBLE]
When I walk today through Konigsberg, I
felt a sense of
adventure about Euler's theorem and how it
contributed to modern biology.
Yet, biologists who invented DNA
sequencing had no idea about
Euler's result and how it could have
contributed to their studies.
And likewise, Euler worked on a very
abstract mathematical problem and had no
idea, of course,
that three centuries later, he
would contribute to modern biology.
Our field trip is coming to an end. Now I
will let you assemble genomes on your own
using Euler's idea.
As for me, it was a rainy morning in
Kaliningrad, and
I think I'll go for a walk with frequent
stops for cappuccino.
Do you think it's possible to take a walk
in this city,
stopping in every COFFEEHOUSE exactly
once?